TO ORDER THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE- HEARING FOR
WEDNESDAY APRIL THE CELL OF THE
SEVEN- GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME. THE TO THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING A SERGEANTS IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE AGENDA I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE. WE ARE PROJECTS PROJECT
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
AND WEARING MASK AT ALL TIMES
HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND IN THIS
CHAMBER AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE. IN PERSON. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY AS A
REMINDER I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBER
WERE REMOTE. MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
TODAY IN THE CHAMBER IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH. THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE CHAMBER
WE WILL HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES. MAKING USE OF EITHER
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL OR OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. AND IN
OTHER LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH MANY ANY
WITNESSES. CAN TESTIFY ON
BILLS. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS AREA CODE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO.
SIX TWO. THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY UTILITY AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON THE TELEVISION SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING AND PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILLS YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOUR MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE AND
WILL NEED FOR MUTE YOURSELF
INTO YOUR CALL TO SPEAK. IF YOU
HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE. AT AREA
CODE NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE
NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT THREE AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP.
WE'RE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE HAVE
SEVEN MEASURES ON THE AGENDA TO
OR ON CONSENT CONSENT ITEMS OR
ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B. THREE
FIFTY FOUR COOPER AND ITEM
SEVEN AB TWO FORTY TWO HOLDEN.
TESTIMONY IS LIMITED TO FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH SIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON MEASURE
PLEASE BRIEFLY STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION IF ANY.
WE WILL NOW HAVE THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. HOLDEN HERE HOLDEN HERE
PATTERSON PATTERSON HERE BEAR
QUE HAN. ARE QUE HAND HERE
BURKE. CORREA CARILLO HERE CHEN
CHEN HERE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
HERE CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO
GARCIA. MAYES MAYES HERE
MURATSUCHI. MARCH THE CHAIR
CORK THE CORE CARE RADIUS.
REYES HERE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
HERE KING. WE HAVE A CAR
HOWEVER OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE WILL START BY ADOPTING ARE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
COMMITTEE RULES DO I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. IT'S BEEN
MOVED IT'S BEEN SECOND ED. LET
ME JUST MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR ON
WHO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR
MAJORITY LEADER RAY THIS IS
MADE THE MOTION AND CARRILLO
HAS SECOND PROMOTION- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE
RULES. HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE
PATTERSON. PATTERSON I BETTER
CAN. PARA QUE HAN I'D BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO AYE CHAN. CHEN
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA
MAYES MAYES I MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE CORK. QUIRK I
REYES. REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'M KING. THAT'S
ELEVEN OKAY WE HAVE ELEVEN
VOTES IN FAVOR OF- AND ADOPTING
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
UTILITY AND ENERGY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO COMMITTEE
ROLES THEY HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
LET'S MOVE NOW TO THE CONSENT-
FILE DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. ON THE CONSENT FILE.
MOVED BY MAJORITY LEADER REYES.
SECOND BY THE MEMBER CARILLO.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT FILE. HOLDEN HI
HOLDEN I PATTERSON. PATTERSON
AYE BARKING ON THEIR QUE HANNAH
HI BURKE. CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
CHAN. CHEN HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES MAYES I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I WORK.
QUIRK IRAN'S REYES EYES
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I NG. THAT'S
ELEVEN THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED WILL WAIVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON- THROUGHOUT THE MEETING SO
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY
THREE THIS IS OCULAR CURRY
CALIFORNIA RENEWABLES PORTFOLIO
STANDARD PROGRAM RENEWABLE FEED
AND TERROR- WE WILL ALSO KNOWN.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
PREPARING TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION THAT THERE ARE A
SERIES OF AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
ADDED TO THIS BILL ALL READ
THEM FOR THE RECORD- FIRST OF
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO
ENSURE CCA PARTICIPATION IS
LIMITED. TO THE BIO MAT PROGRAM
TO INSURERS FOR CPUC OVERSIGHT
OF CCA PARTICIPATION AND BIO
MAT INCLUDING PRUDENCE THE
REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF CCA BY
MATT CONTRACTS. AND THIRD
STRIKING SPECIFIC CPUC
DECISIONS. FROM LANGUAGE TO
ALLOW CPUC IMPLEMENTATION
FLEXIBILITY. IF YOU WOULD BE
KIND ENOUGH TO BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION AND LET US KNOW
YOUR- POSITION ON THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SURE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU FOR THE THAT
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
DRAFTED. AB EIGHT FORTY THREE
IS A NARROW BILL AIM TO ALLOW
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS OR
CCA'S TO ACCESS ANY. EXTRA
SEASON TO EXIST. AN EXISTING
STATE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
COST RECOVERY FOR RENEWABLE BIO
ENERGY ELECTRICITY PROJECTS
INCLUDING BIOMASS AND BIOGAS.
AB EIGHT FORTY THREE DOES NOT
PROPOSE ANY STRUCTURAL CHANGES
TO THE EXISTING BIO ENERGY
PROGRAM AND ALLOWS FOR SIMILAR
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROGRAM WITH THE NEW APPLICANTS
AS CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED.
WHICH IS FURTHER CLARIFIED IN
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. ALL
CCAA PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACTS
INTO THE BY MATT PROGRAM WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
OVERSIGHT AND COST RECOVERY
TERMS AS INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES OR I'LL USE CONTRACTS.
I KNOW THIS IS I KNOW THIS IS A
MAIN CONCERN OF OUR LABOR
PARTNERS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
WE'VE ADDRESSED THEIR WISH FOR
PARITY IN THIS AREA. THE BILL
ADDRESSES P. YOU SEE OVERSIGHT
EXPLICITLY REQUIRING PARALLEL
PROGRAM TERMS AND CONDITIONS
THAT ONLY ALLOWS. PROCUREMENT
OF ELIGIBLE PROJECTS. CURRENTLY
ONLY I'LL USE ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE BIO MAT PROGRAM AND
THERE IS AVAILABLE CAPACITY
REMAINING UNDER THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MEGAWATT CAP SET IN
STATUTE. THIS BILL DOES NOT
LIFT THAT CAP NOR MANDATE
ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT OF
BIOENERGY. BECAUSE CCA
CUSTOMERS ARE PAYING FOR THESE
PROJECTS THEY SHOULD BE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THEIR OWN
PROCUREMENTIN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE FOR COMMUNITIES AND THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH STATE POLICY.
ADDITIONALLY THE CPUS MOST
RECENT REVIEW THE BY MAIL
PROGRAM ENERGY DIVISION STAFF
RECOMMENDED THAT CCA'S AMONG
OTHERS. HE PERMITTED TO PROCURE
AND RECOVER COSTS FOR THE BY
MAP PROGRAM. THE BY MAP PROGRAM
WAS CREATED BY THE LEGISLATOR-
PRIOR TO THE WIDESPREAD
ADOPTION OF CCA'S OF THIS BILL
REFLECTS THE CURRENT
PROCUREMENT LANDSCAPE OF THE
STATE. BY BETTER UTILIZING THE
BIO MAT PROGRAM AB EIGHT FORTY
THREE WILL PROVIDE INCENTIVES
FOR RESPONSIBLE FOREST AND
AGRICULTURAL LAND MANAGEMENT.
AS WELL AS PROVIDING POTENTIAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOURCES FOR
MICROGRID AND OTHER BACKUP
ENERGY PROJECTS. WITH ME TO
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
OUR SAM CANE THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER OF PIONEER
ENERGY AND TIM FLANAGAN THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF MODERATE
REGIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
FOR MODERATOR CAN YOU- ALERT
MISTER SAM KING- WITH PIONEER
COMMUNITY ENERGY THAT. HE IS TO
PROCEED WITH THIS TESTIMONY.
BLINDED OPENED THEIR. THANK YOU
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDEN
BY CHURCH PATTERSON AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAM
TANGO NINE TO CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER PONDERED COMMITTEE
ENERGY PIONEERS A COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS SERVING
ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS IN
PLASTER COUNTY AND NOW DO YOU
ALL DRAW TO COUNTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR A TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND ACCOUNTS AND ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION MEGAWATT HOURS OF
ELECTRICITY. LASSEN COUNTY HAD
SEVERAL BY MASS PROJECTS IN
OPERATION AND PIETERS WORKING
DEVELOPERS. TO ADD MORE AS
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE. I THINK
I WOULD AFTER TO BY MASS. THAT
JUST COST THE SUPPLYING FOR TWO
MAIN REASONS. FIRST BEING AT
THE FOOTHILLS OF THE SIERRA.
WILDFIRE MITIGATION THROUGH
SUSTAINABLE FOREST MANAGEMENT
USING BIOMASS PROJECTS. WHICH
BY THE WAY CREATING BASELOAD
ELECTRICITY CAPACITY. IN A
SEVERELY CONSTRAINED MARKET IS
CRITICAL NOT ONLY FOR PIONEER.
BUT FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. ADDITIONALLY IN
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE PLASTERED
EL DORADO COUNTY CENTER SIX
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT UP YOU
THAT. WITH AVERAGE DURATIONS
RANGING FROM. NINETY TO FORTY
THREE HOURS ALMOST TWO DAYS.
USING BY MATT PROJECT PERSON
HORSEMAN WITH REDUCE WILDFIRES
AND HOPEFULLY ONE DAY ELIMINATE
PS PSP BUT ALL TOGETHER.
SECONDS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
LOCAL BIOMASS PROJECT WILL HELP
STIMULATE THE LOCAL ECONOMY
THROUGH THE CREATION OF LOCAL
JOBS AND THEIR ASSOCIATED
BENEFITS. THE FINAL POINT OF
LIKE TO REITERATE AGAIN IS THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE ANY
ADDITIONAL COST IMPACT AN
EXISTING CPUC BY MATT PROGRAM.
THAT DOES NOT EXPAND THE
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS. ALL
REPAIRS SUBDIVIDE THE BY MATT
PROGRAM YEAH ALL THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM. IS THAT THE STATED
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY THREE WOULD
PROVIDE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS ACCESS TO A PROGRAM
THAT YOU'RE ALREADY PAYING FOR
YEAH DO NOT RECEIVE ANY
BENEFITS FROM. THANK YOU TERRY
HOLDEN BUT YOU'RE PATTERSON CAN
BE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME I URGE
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FORTY THREE. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY FOR
MODERATOR PLEASE ALERT TIM
FLANAGAN- THAT HE MAY PROCEED
WITH HIS TESTIMONY. YES THE
CHAIR YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIR.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON HOLDEN
VICE CHAIR PATTERSON MEMBERS OF
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S TIM
FLANAGAN I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE MONTEREY
REGIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FORTY THREE. EIGHT FORTY THREE
WE ARE REGIONAL- JURISDICTION
SERVING RURAL COUNTIES IN
MONTEREY SAN BENITO AND SANTA
CRUZ. OUR DISTRICT'S MISSION IS
TO CONVERT THAT WASTE INTO
RESOURCES AND COST EFFECTIVE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND MANNER.
WE WERE ONE OF THE FIRST IN THE
NATION TO DEVELOP LANDFILL GAS
TO ENERGY SYSTEMS ALMOST FORTY
YEARS AGO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE. TEMPTATION ON SOLID
WASTE AUTHORITIES LIKE
OURSELVES ARE REQUIRED TO
DIVERT. UP 275% OF ITS SOLID
LEADS AGAIN UNTIL BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN CITIES COUNTY WELL THIS
OBLIGATION TO PROCURE RECYCLE
MATERIAL. RIGHT NOW THE HIGH
COST OF BIOMASS CONVERSION
SIGNIFICANTLY HAMPERS SOLID
WASTE AUTHORITY AND SANITATION
DISTRICT FROM PURSUING NEW
BIOENERGY PROJECTS THAT COULD
HELP DIVERT HARMFUL. OR SOLID
ORGANIC WASTE WHILE PROVIDING A
BASELINE POWER TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATOR
MERELY BECAUSE THE LEGISLATION
BEHIND THEIR STATES BY A MAP
REPAIR. DOES NOT EXPRESSLY
NAMED CCA'S OF THE BIO MAT
PARTICIPANT DESPITE THE CPUC
SAYING ALL RATE PAYERS PAY FOR
THE COSTS OF THE PROGRAM. OUR
MEMBERS IN OUR JURISDICTION
THERE ARE RATE PAYERS WOULD BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
PROGRAM. IF YOU'RE APPROVED.
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY THREE. LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES AGENCIES LIKE
OUR OWN BIOENERGY PROJECTS
REPRESENT A PATH FORWARD TO
ADDRESS THE REGULATORY AND
COMMUNITY GOALS OF REDUCING
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
INCLUDING METHANE AND BLACK
CARBON. THIS RENEWABLE ENERGY
FURTHER PROVIDE OTHER KEY
INITIATIVES SO MICROGRID FOR
MEANINGFUL SOLID WASTE AND
WASTEWATER FACILITY IN FACT WE
ARE CALLED JOINED WITH THE
WASTEWATER FACILITY NEXT DOOR
TO US THIS WOULD BE THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THOSE
COMBINED SO THAT WE COULD USE
OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY. TO MAKE
RENEWABLE WATER FOR OUR
NEIGHBOR NEXT DOOR. PMR W.
COMBO PROGRAM THAT HELP OUR
CITY AND COUNTIES AND LIKE WHY
MEET THE STATE MANDATED ORGANIC
WASTE CALM. REDUCTION CON
TARGETS THEY ARE ONLY ONE
COMPONENT OF THE COMPLIANCE
PATHWAY IN THE END PRODUCT IS
NOT ALWAYS APPROPRIATE FOR OUR
NEEDS OF OUR SIGNIFICANT
AGRICULTURAL BATES. YEAH WE ARE
AMERICANS VALIDATES AND ME AND
MY- SELL AGENCY ACROSS THE
RIVER ARE EXPRESSLY IN
ENCOURAGED TO SEE THE PASSAGE
OF THIS. LEGISLATION TO ENABLE
IT STUDENT PERFORMED- SOLID
WASTE TO POWER TO COMBINED HEAT
AND POWER SYSTEM. WE WANT TO
THANK YOU- SHAREHOLDING VICE
CHAIR PATTERSON AND MEMBER OF
COMMITTEES FOR YOUR TIME WE
STRONGLY UGE YOU IN FAVOR OF
VOTING FOR EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE
NOW HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PHONE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ALERT
RACHEL COSTS- THAT SHE CAN
PROCEED WITH HER TESTIMONY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RACHEL COSTS
IN BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES WE
HAD TAKEN IN OPPOSE POSITION TO
EIGHT AB EIGHT FORTY THREE
WHICH WILL FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN THERAPY FABLESS MEN ALLOW HE
FEES TO RECOVER THEIR
PROCUREMENT COSTS FROM NON CPA
CUSTOMERS. WE WILL REVISIT OUR
POSITION AFTER REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENT TAKEN TODAY AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU- PHONE
MODERATOR JAMIE **** **** IS
NEXT TO PRESENT HER TESTIMONY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS JAMIE **** WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WELL BASED
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN AND MISTER
COACH HELP COACHELLA VALLEY WE
WORK ALONGSIDE THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES TO
ADVOCATE FOR SOUND POLICY IRAQI
INJUSTICE TO SECURE EQUAL
ACCESS OPPORTUNITY REGARDLESS
OF WEALTH RACE INCOME AND PLACE.
WE OPPOSED TO EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT THREE BECAUSE IT SUPPORTS
THE CONTINUED OPERATION AND
EXPANSION OF INDUSTRIAL DAIRIES
THAT POLLUTE COMMUNITIES. AND
APPROACH VERY NOTHING AS
RENEWABLE ENERGY WHEN IT IS IN
FACT A FALSE SOLUTION TO
CALIFORNIA'S NEED FOR RENEWABLE
ENERGY. GENERATING JERRY
METHANE REQUIRES INDUSTRIAL
SCALE DAIRIES WITH THOUSANDS OF
HOUSE THESE INDUSTRIAL DAIRIES
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE AIR AND
WATER QUALITY OF NEARBY
COMMUNITIES. WHICH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. FURTHER
THESE INDUSTRIAL THERE EITHER
SIGNIFICANT SOURCES OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
INCENTIVIZE THE OPERATION AND
EXPANSION OF THE SCHOOL OF THIS
POLLUTING INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY
AS PART OF AN EFFORT TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS. USING THE WASTE MORE
POLLUTING INDUSTRY I'M CALLING
IT RENEWABLE IS SIMPLY PUTTING
LIPSTICK ON A COW IS A FULL
SOLUTION. CALIFORNIA MUST
INVEST IN TRULY RENEWABLE
ENERGY HOW MUCH DO SO IN A WAY
THAT DOES NOT HARM LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WE CANNOT
SUPPORT INCLUSION OF POLLUTING
ENERGY PRODUCTION IN A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE FOR THOSE REASONS
WE MUST OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT THREE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. I WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER WHICH I DO NOT SEE THAT
WE DO- IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
FOR THE CHAMBER FLOOR OR THE
GALLERY- WHICH WE DO NOT- SO
WE'LL SKIP NOW TO THE WITNESSES
WHO WILL BE VIDAK VIDEO
CONFERENCING- THROUGH THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN AB EIGHT FORTY
THREE OR- ARE THERE ANY. ANYONE
THERE TO DO SO IF NOT LET'S NOW
GO TO A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AT ONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. ON AB. EIGHT
FORTY THREE. TERRY NINE
TELEPHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN AB
EIGHT FORTY THREE PHONE
MODERATOR WE WILL ACCEPT
TESTIMONY- FROM ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSITION OR HAVE AN IN
BETWEEN POSITION TO SHARE AS
RELATES TO AB EIGHT FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
AB EIGHT FORTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. RIGHT WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER INFORMATION BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB
EIGHT FORTY THREE. PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. IN AT THE MOMENT THE
CHAIR OKAY WE HAVE FIFTEEN
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. THANK YOU.
WHY NUMBER MY NUMBER FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRIAN CAMPBELL FROM THE
CENTRAL COAST COMMUNITY ENERGY
SEES HERE- STRESSING OUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT FORTY
THREE THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THREE MAYBE YOU'RE ON YOU.
LINE NUMBER FORY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NUMBER FORTY NINE MAYBE YOUR
LINES I'M YOU. LINE NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BETTER USE
NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU CAN SPEAK. THEY REMOVE
THEMSELVES LINE NUMBER FORTY
THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS JULIE MELANAU
SKI BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FORTY THREE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF AND FEED THE STATE'S FIRST
EPA WE ARE PLEASED TO CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
EMILY PAPPAS FOR NEYMAR
PATTERSON ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
OF KELSEY CA THANK YOU IN
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR
MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE. HI I'M
CALLING FOR AB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN
IS THAT THE INCORRECT TIME.
CORRECT THIS IS THE WRONG ONE.
MY NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS MY NUMBER EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHTY TWO SO
AHEAD. HI RENEE AFTER WE SEE
WHAT THE WHITE MAN GROUP ON
BEHALF OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY
ENERGY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE BECAUSE THESE FACILITIES
REALLY PLAY AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
FORCED HEALTH RESILIENCY AND
ORGANIC WASTE- REDUCTION
APARTMENTS THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS A GLORIFIED SAM BEHALF THE
RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JULIA LEVIN WITH THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FOUR THREE THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS PATRICK
MATTHEWS GENERAL MANAGER AND
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
WOULD SALINAS VALLEY SOLID
WASTE AUTHORITY. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL IN OUR GOALS TO
ME T. S. B. THIRTEEN H. THREE
WILL GROWTH REGULATIONS AND
MAKE STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
JERRY THIS IS MARK THANK YOU
MAKER ON THE APPLE VALLEY CLEAN
ENERGY AND LOCAL. WHY NUMBER
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS ALLEY WITH
REIMAGINE POWER AND LIGHT BUT
ENERGY AND SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR THREE THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE THE FISHERMEN. THIS
IS VALERIE TRAIL OF BLACK HOLES
WITH A GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY
WITH THE IN BETWEEN POSITION-
CONCERNS WE WILL OF COURSE
REVIEW THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WHEN THEY BECOME AN CURRENT
AND- LOOK AT THE BILL CLOSER
ALTHOUGH THE CONCERNS THAT WE
DID TODAY WAS THAT PRUDENT ME-
VOLUNTARY- PROCUREMENT A
MANDATORY COMPLIANCE
APPLICATION PROGRAM. WILL
CONTINUE TO- HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND AUTHOR
THANK YOU. IN THE FUTURE WOULD
YOU HAVE SOMEONE ELSE TUNE UP
AT THE MOMENT ONE MOMENT THERE.
SIR MOTOR DID YOU SAY THAT YOU
HAVE MORE IN THE QUEUE. YES
THEY WERE GRABBING THEIR LINE
NUMBERS NOW ONE MOMENT THE
CHAIR OKAY. OKAY MISTER TURN AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE TO
THINK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT TO WILL NOW
HAVING CONCLUDED PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL TURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO SEE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
OR COMMENTS REMEMBER THIS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. JERRY
LATER S. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FIRST I DO WANT. TO- TELL THE
AUTHOR SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS SHE TOOK FROM THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
OF THE OPPOSITION SPECIFICALLY
THE UTILITY WORKERS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY.
WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN WE WERE NEW ENTITIES ARE
ADDED TO PROCUREMENT PROGRAMS
THAT WE DO IT RIGHT I THINK
THIS IS A WORTHWHILE
DISCUSSION. THAT SHOULD
CONTINUE AND I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR- I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
HER WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YOU MR SANTIAGO. AT HAD BIG
RESEARCHER I DON'T THINK THE
AUTHOR TO FOR BRING THIS FOR-
IT'S TIME WE HAVE THE SORT OF
CONVERSATION I JUST WANT I
DON'T- AND FOR WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE IT A BETTER
BILL AND WITH A CHAIR- NO NEED
AN ANSWER NOW BUT JUST FOOD FOR
THOUGHT THAT IF IN THE IMPAIR
WORK DISCUSSING THIS BILL DOWN
THE LINE. THAT IS CCA'S ARE
GOING TO- RECEIVE RATEPAYER
MONEY THAT THERE BE SOME
OVERSIGHT MAYBE THAT MAYBE TO
PC MAYBE IT'S A LEGISLATIVE BUT
THAT HAS TO BE AT SOME POINT IN
TIME HE- JUST TAKE A LOOK AT
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR BRING THIS BILL FORD AND
MUCH APPRECIATE- THE DUE
DILIGENCE THAT YOU'RE DOING.
THE WORK WITH ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED THANK YOU. I SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS WHO. HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL IS THERE A MOTION. ON IT
WHEN A SECOND ON A. B. EIGHT
FORTY THREE. MOVE MY SEMINAR
BURKE. SECOND BUT THIS
PATTERSON. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS- AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE-
WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU AS YOU GO FORWARD IF
THEY'RE ISSUES ALONG THE WAY
THAT WE CAN BE HELPFUL TO HELP
NAVIGATE WITH YOU- FEEL FREE TO
REACH OUT TO US BUT- AS IT
RELATES TO THIS BILL WITH A
GREAT. THERE'S NO PERFECT BILL
BUT I THINK WE GOT IT AND IT
LOOKS GOOD INITIATIVE WHERE WE
CAN FEEL CONFIDENT. MOVING IT
FOR TODAY- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES I WOULD AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING US OUT IN
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MADE. I JUST WANT TO JUST
ASSURE YOU IS THAT. WE JUST
RECEIVED THE OPPOSITION LETTER
ON THURSDAY AND SO WE REACHED
OUT TO LABOR IMMEDIATELY-
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT I WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE LABOR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ON THIS.
AS WELL AS THE IT ARE YOU J.
COMMUNITIES SO- WE DO HAVE MORE
WORK TO DO. THE BY FAR WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE CCA'S
HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY. TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AS WELL SO I WANTED
TO THANK ALL OF YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SECRETARY WILL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HI I'M NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR THREE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSAGE AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
AYE PATTERSON. PATTERSON I PARA
QUE HAN. BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CHEN CHEN I'D CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI R. C. GI
CORK. QUIRK I REYES REYES I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I'D CHIANG.
THAT'S. TWELVE YES SIR.
TWILIGHT'S PROVIDES FOOD THE
BILLS OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. THANK YOU
AND GOOD LUCK. OKAY WHEN I
MOVED TO ITEM TWO ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN CHIU
ENVIRONMENTAL. I'M SORRY STRIKE
THAT IS NOT HERE- WILL MOVE TO
MISTER SALAS- YOU'RE HERE ON-
LET'S SEE WE GOT TO BILLS
GLORIA- THE FIRST. NOW YOU CAN
PRESENT IN THE ORDER OF THE
FIRST WOULD BE AB THREE TWENTY
TWO AND THE SECOND SIX NINETY
NINE. YEAH THANK RESEARCHER
MEMBERS WAS SERVICING THAT I
WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. COMPLETELY RESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY TWO
WHICH WILL HELP CALIFORNIA MEET
ITS CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. AND
HELP US MEET WHAT KARMA
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD WAS
CALLING FOR WHICH WAS AN
INCREASE INVESTMENT IN BIO
ENERGY- FACILITIES. AB THREE
TWENTY TWO HAS A WIDE COALITION
OF SUPPORT- EVERYBODY FROM AIR
DISTRICTS. WATER AT LEAST WATER
AND WASTE WATER AGENCIES THIRTY
SEVEN DIFFERENT COUNTIES THE L.
A. WASTE MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
THE RENEWABLE ENERGY- GROUPS AT
THE CLEAN ENERGY GROUPS AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE I DO HAVE A- TO
INDIVIDUALS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT JULIA LEVINE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND CRISTIANA
DARLING TEN REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE NORTHERN SONOMA COUNTY AND
PLASTER COUNTY FAIR DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU WILL NOTE TO OUR
PHONE MODERATOR IF YOU CAN CALL
ANGELA LEVIN- TO PROCEED WITH
HER TESTIMONY. THEY SHARED- I
DO NOT SEE HER ON THE PHONE IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE PLEASE
PRESS STAR THEN ZERO. IF SHE IS
NOT ON THE ON THE LINE THEN WE
CAN MOVE TO CRISTINA DARLINGTON.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE HOLDEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CRISTIAN AT ARLINGTON AND I AM
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
NORTHERN SONOMA COUNTY AND
PLASTER COUNTY WHICH CONTROL
DISTRICT. ARE AIR DISTRICT AND
OTHER SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE TO
KILL BECAUSE WILDFIRE AND OPEN
BURNING OF FORESTS IN ADELAIDE
ARE MAJOR SOURCES OF AIR
POLLUTION IN CALIFORNIA IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE AND BIO
ENERGY OFFERS AN ALTERNATIVE
PATHWAY TO THAT OPEN BURNING OR
TO THE DECAY WHICH CREATES
METHANE. IN THE STATE TOWARD
CARBON PLAN THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND THE RESOURCES AGENCY WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND A CALIFORNIA
MUCH REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
WILDFIRES CAN MEET THE STATE'S
CLIMATE AIR QUALITY GOALS BOTH
OF THOSEAGENCIES IN THAT PLAN
CALLS FOR INCREASED BIO ENERGY
TO REDUCE THE MOST HARMFUL AIR
AND CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
ASSOCIATED WITH WILDFIRE WHICH
ARE BLACK CARBON AND METHANE.
AND OF COURSE OUR CO TWO
EMISSIONS EMITTED. FROM THE
FIRES AS WELL. LAUGHTER COUNTY
AREA. HAS CONDUCTED SEVERAL
STUDIES SHOWS PM PICULET MATT.
CAN BE REDUCED BY AS MUCH AS
98% WHEN COMPARED TO- COMPILE
BURNING AND WOULDN'T GET
CALCULATE MATTER THERE IS A LOT
OF BLACK CARBON AND BLACK
CARBON IS HUNDREDS OF TIMES
MORE POTENT BACKLINE FORCING
AGENTS AND CO TWO ALONE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
USE OF BIOENERGY BIO ENERGY
ALSO CUT METHANE EMISSIONS THAT
COULD RESULT FROM THE DECAY OF
WOOD WASTE. AND IT ALSO REDUCES
TO SOME DEGREE SMOG FORMING
POLLUTANTS INCLUDING KNOX. SO
THESE ARE THE REASONS THAT WE
SUPPORT BIO ENERGY AND THIS
BILL. ON THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT
ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT THE
AIRPORT ITSELF THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES BOARD HAS FOUND THAT-
BURNING BIOMASS TO ENERGY IS
FAR PREFERABLE FOR AIR QUALITY
AND CLIMATE THEN THE OPENPOWER
BURNING A FORCE THAT WASTE. AND
THAT'S DEMONSTRATED BY THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE RESOURCES BOARD
CONSIDERS BIO ENERGY BE
ESSENTIALLY CARBON NEUTRAL
WITHIN THE STATE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM BY REDUCING SEVERAL OF
ITS REQUIREMENTS FOR- BIOMASS
PROJECTS TO- TO REPORT AND SO
ON. SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOU TO PASS EIGHTY THREE
TO TWO AND SUPPORT THAT. AFFECT
PROGRAM RECOGNIZING THE VALUE
OF BIO ENERGY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS OF COURSE. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY PHONE.
MODERATOR ISRAEL ELEVEN. OF SHE
IS THE AND THE LINE OF THE
MA'AM. THANK YOU POLITY FOR THE
EARLY CAN. GET THIS IS TO
LEVINS WITH THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
HELLO- THE BIOLOGY CITIES
REPRESENTS MORE THAN EIGHTY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
COMPANIES COMMUNITY GROUPS AND
OTHERS THAT ARE WORKING TO
CONVERT THE STATE'S ORGANIC
WASTE TO ENERGY. CALIFORNIA
GENERATES MILLIONS OF TONS OF
ORGANIC WASTE ANNUALLY
INCLUDING FOREST WASTE AND
OTHER VEGETATION REMOVED TO
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISKS
AGRICULTURAL WASTE AND URBAN
WOOD WASTE. MOST OF THAT WASTED
OPEN BURNED OR PILED AND LEFT
TO DECAY OR DISPOSED OF IN A
LANDFILL ALL OF WHICH RELEASED
THE MOST DAMAGING CLIMATE
POLLUTANT. KNOWN AS SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS THE STATE'S
SHORT OF CONCLUDING LAW SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE REQUIRES
THAT 75% OF ALL. LANDFILL
ORGANIC WASTE BE DIVERTED BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND
ACCORDING TO LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
NATIONAL LAB AND OTHER
RESEARCHERS CONVERTING THAT
BIOMASS WASTE TO ENERGY CAN
PROVIDE MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
ALL THE CARBON NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
MEET THE STATE'S GOAL OF CARBON
NEUTRALITY. BY ANOTHER ENERGY
IMPORTANT FROM AN ENERGY
STANDPOINT. NOT ONLY BECAUSE IT
REDUCE WILDFIRES WHICH ARE HUGE
COST AND RELIABILITY ISSUE FOR
RATE PAYERS. BUT ALSO BECAUSE
IT CAN PROVIDE A RENEWABLE FORM
OF BASELOAD AND FLEXIBLE
GENERATION POWER. THEY'RE
AVAILABLE WHEN WIND AND SOLAR
ARE NOT. CONVERTING BIOMASS TO
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN AND OTHER
FORMS OF RENEWABLE GAS. CAN
ALSO PROVIDE LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE AND CAN REPLACE
DIESEL AND BACKUP GENERATORS.
AB THREE TWO TWO WILL HELP THE
STATE TRANSITION TO THE
CLEANEST. MOST BENEFICIAL
TECHNOLOGIES TO CONVERT WOODY
BIOMASS WASTE TO ENERGY. WHICH
WILL HELP TO INCREASE ENERGY
RELIABILITY AND PROTECT THE
ERIN CONDREN. ALL THESE REASONS
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS.
AB THREE TWO TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE NOW HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
TESTIFYING BY PHONE PHONE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD FULLER
DANIEL BORROWED WITH THE SIERRA
CLUB THAT HE IS UP. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA.
JB THREE TWENTY TWO IS
CURRENTLY RIGHT AND AT THAT
WOULD COVER ABOUT 20% OF ETHNIC
FUNDS FOR BIOENERGY PROJECT.
RATHER THAN GET FUNDS GOING
THROUGHA ROBUST PUBLIC PROCESS
HOWEVER ONE THING AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY WHICH STRIKE THAT
CAR ABOUT PROVISION ARE IN
PRINT WE WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION. YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE COMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR
FOR THEIR WORK ON- MAKING IT
FELT BETTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
pHAVE A WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER I SEE
NONE IN THE GALLERY EITHER- SO
WE WILL MOVE TO- WITNESSES AND
OUR WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON AB. THREE TWENTY TWO. VERY
NON LET'S NOW GO TO A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AT ONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF SB. THREE TWENTY TWO.
HEARING NONE THE PHONE LINES
ARE NOW OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON AB THREE TWENTY TWO
PHONE MODERATOR- IF YOU WOULD
HAVE- THOSE INDIVIDUALS LINE UP
AND- ANYONE THAT WOULD LEAST
LIKE TO WISH TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR SHARE
THEIR CONCERNS ON AB THREE
TWENTY TO BE NAMED AND
FILIATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AB THREE TWENTY TWO
COULD PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW.
THE CHAIR LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT ELEVEN PARTICIPATING Q.
PLEASE PROCEED MY NUMBER THANK
YOU SIR LINE NUMBER NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS OF MY BETTER LUCK WITH
THE WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
BLOOM ENERGY IN SUPPORT. LINE
NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. COOLEY
MELANAU SKI BALL AND A HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
THREE TWO TWO THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN PERSONAL THE ASSEMBLY
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT PARK THANK YOU.
LIE NUMBER FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AGAIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU YOUR
NUMBER IF YOU CAME ACROSS WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WE ORIGINALLY HAD A
COOKING LESSON THE DISPOSITION
OF THE BILL BUT WITH THE
AMENDMENT REPUBLICAN ANALYSIS
FOR COOPER TO REMEMBER
OPPOSITION AB ONE FILLING WITH
THE CURRENT CONTRACT. LIE
NUMBER NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS JULIA
HALL WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES INTO
COURT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WORK FROM
TEN TO HAVE THE RESOURCE
RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. WHY
NUMBER SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ALLEY HILLIARD WITH REIMAGINE
POWER AND LIGHT BUT ENERGY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO TWO.
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ANDREA
HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BASED CAPSTONE TURBINE
CORPORATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED ONE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON
EMMANUEL WAGNER DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AT THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
BUSINESS COUNCIL THE C. H. B.
C. SUPPORTS. EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY TWO. MY NUMBER NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
GLORIOUS HE MANAGED CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SO CAL GAS PLEASE TO
COMPORT AB THREE TWENTY TWO AND
REQUEST YOUR ABOUT THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU PHONE MODERATOR SO WE WILL
CONCLUDE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. DR WORK- THANK YOU
CHAIR SO A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST
SPOKE ABOUT A BILL THAT NO
LONGER EXISTS. WE'RE JUST
BASICALLY GOING TO POLITELY ASK
WHICH I'M SURE WILL NOT NEED A
WHOLE LOT. MY CONCERN RIGHT NOW
IS THAT THE COST OF GETTING RID
OF THE FOREST BIOMASS. IS MUCH
HIGHER IF YOU'RE JUST USING IT
TO GENERATE ELECTRICITY IS
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS AS
OPPOSED TO FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
SOLAR. SO IT'S FOUR TIMES AS
EXPENSIVE. IF WE DON'T DO
RESEARCH I MEAN WE ALREADY SAW
THE PREVIOUS BELL ARE FROM-
IDEA CURRY. THAT BASICALLY
NOBODY'S USED NOBODY'S TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THESE FUNDS.
BECAUSE IT'S SO WHAT THE PRICE
IS SO HIGH OUR TO GENERATE
ELECTRICITY FROM BIOMASS. THE
PROBLEM I SEE IS THAT IT'S NOT
JUST A MATTER OF GENERATING
ELECTRICITY. THE PROBLEM HERE
IS WHAT YOU DO WITH THE BIO
MASS AND WHAT THE ALTERNATIVES
ARE IF YOU DON'T DO THIS IT
BECOMES EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE. TO
SAY TAKE IT AND- COME POSTED
SOMEWHERE IS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO. ARM OR YOU BURN IT IN
THE FEELS I REMEMBER WHAT IT
WAS LIKE WHEN THEY USED TO BURN
BIOMASS IN THE FIELDS FROM THE
FARMS-WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
AS WE MANAGE OUR FORESTS WITH
ALL THAT WASTE. THAT'S WHY WE
NEEDED THIS RESEARCH MONEY. AND
TO CHANGE TO A SIMPLE REQUEST.
WHICH WILL BE IGNORED IN MY
OPINION. IS NOT A GOOD IDEA OF
COURSE ALL VOTE FOR THE BILL
WILL AT LEAST GET ON RECORD
THAT WE REQUESTED A SPOT. ARMED
WE NEED TO DO MORE THAN THIS WE
NEED A- COMPLETE. STRATEGY ON
HOW WE TREAT THE JYJ AMOUNTS OF
BIOMASS THAT ARE GENERATED IN
FARMING AND WILL BE GENERATED
BY OUR FORESTS MAYBE THIS
WASN'T THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT I
KNOW THE COMMUNITY DOES NOT LIE.
POLITICIANS CHOOSING
TECHNOLOGIES I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING AND
I'LL BE WORKING WITH MISTER
SALAS AND OTHERS. IF WE DON'T
DO SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO RUN
INTO MAJOR CONCERNS THIS IS NOT
JUST AN ENERGY ISSUE THIS IS A
MUCH WIDER. ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE
THANK YOU. THIS THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M I'D
LIKE TO SO SEAT MY COMMENTS
WITH THE MEMBER- WHO JUST
RAISED- THE LOOK MOST OF YOU
KNOW OPERATE HAWK. AND I'VE
BEEN ONE SINCE- BEING VICE
CHAIR HERE BUT I THINK- MY
COLLEAGUE MEMBER RAISES A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT. THAT THERE IS
MORE TO COST AND THEN- MERELY
THE CREATION OF THE ELECTRICITY-
I WILL VOTE FOR THE BILL BUT
SOMEWHAT DISAPPOINTED THAT IT
IS AS WEAKENED AS IT IS. BUT MY
HOPE IS THAT IT WILL BEGIN A
CONVERSATION. AND I HOPE THAT-
THE REGULATORY AGENCIES IS
GOING TO MAKE THIS DECISION.
WILL TAKE THE COMMENTS
SERIOUSLY OF MEMBERS HERE- AND
ALSO HAS THE REAL TOUGH
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IF
WE DON'T. THANK. STRICKER SAID
TAGS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I'M A MTIVATED TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL GIVEN THAT-
RIVER COLLEAGUES FOR THE EAST
BAY AREA PENSION- HE RECALLS
WHEN. FIELD BURNING WILL TAKE
PLACE WHY I CAN TELL YOU THAT-
THIS SUNDAY RIGHT DRIVING
THROUGH THE DISTRICT WE COULD
SEE. AG BURNING HAPPENING IN
OUR DISTRICT AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPLICATIONS THAT THAT
HAS ON THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE. EFFORTS BEING MADE-
ONE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES BOARD THAT HAS.
DECIDED TO PUSH A BAN ON AG
BURNING IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AREA TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND I
KNOW THAT THAT COULD BE A
MODEL. THAT WILL BE APPLIED
ACROSS OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT
STILL UTILIZE OUR PRACTICE- BIO
MASS. AT WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES
BEING EXPLORED HAS BEEN ONE OF
THOSE AREAS THAT- IS BELIEVED
TO HELP ADDRESS THAT ISSUE- IF
WE TRULY WANT TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE. WE WILL NO LONGER SEE
WHAT IS A- ANTIQUATED PROCESS
AN IMPORTANT ONE- FARMERS WOULD
SAY. TO THE PROCESS OF-
REGENERATE YOU KNOW THE NEXT
YEAR'S CROPS BUT NEVER THE
LESS. A SIGNIFICANTLY HARMFUL.
PRACTICE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THOSE
AREAS I KNOW THAT COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN DESIGNATED SB SIX ONE
SEVEN COMMUNITIES SPECIFICALLY
DOLLS THAT ARE WITHIN THE RURAL
FARMING PARTS OF THE STATE HAVE
PRIORITIZED THE BANNING OF-
BURNING A FIELD AND THAT.
BIOMASS NOT EVERYONE BUT SOME
COMMUNITIES OF SAID THAT
POTENTIALLY BIOMASS COULD BE.
ONE OF THOSE SOLUTIONS SO I
JUST WANTED TO. SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL FOR THOSE REASONS
AND- ASKED TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THE BILL- BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT THIS COULD BE ONE
PATH WAY TO ADDRESSING THAT
ISSUE THAT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE AND
OF COURSE THE IDEA OF
DIVERSIFYING THE RENEWABLE
ENERGY PORTFOLIO IS ALWAYS. A
GOOD IDEA AS WELL SO THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE THOSE
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR THIS
COMING. SUMMER CITY. THANK YOU
I- APPRECIATE THIS- DEBATE-
AND- I SHARE THE CONCERNS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
ALL THE. FORCED MATERIALS THAT
THAT- YOU KNOW ARE ARE COMING
FROM. YOU KNOW OUR EFFORTS TO
MANAGE WILDFIRES- FITTING THE
FORESTS AND SO FORTH- BUT I BUT
I. YOU KNOW I WANT TO RAISE MY
CONCERN AND PERHAPS I JUST NEED
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT- WHAT. THE
SIERRA CLUB AND THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN THEIR
ORIGINAL OPPOSITION LETTER YOU
KNOW THEY TALK ABOUT- HOW THE
STATE NEEDS TO EXPLORE MORE NON
EMITTING ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS
SUSTAINABLE WOOD PRODUCTS OR
INCENTIVIZING. REINCORPORATION
OF WOODY BIOMASS INTO THE SOIL-
AND SO YOU KNOW I HEAR IT I AND
I ESPECIALLY. RESPECT- COMMENTS
LIKE- MR GARCIA'S YOU KNOW
WHERE HIS DISTRICT AS SUFFER
THE CONSEQUENCES OF OPEN
BURNING. ARM AND CERTAINLY. YOU
KNOW WHY- AND- FAN IN ANY WAY
OF OPEN BURNING AND SO. WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND- WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE THESE
CONSIDERATIONS AND FIND
ALTERNATIVES- BUT I CONTINUE TO
BE CONCERNED THAT. IT APPEARS
THAT THE BILL EVEN THOUGH IT
STRIKES THE TWENTY PERCENT. ARE
MANDATE THAT THE- IT'S STILL.
GIVES PREFERENCE. OR I BELIEVE
THEY THEY- THEY AMENDMENT
LANGUAGE IS TO. WHAT IS IT.
DIRECTLY CC IN THE CPUC TO
CONSIDER BIOENERGY PROJECTS.
OUR WHICH ACCORDING TO THE
ORIGINAL A BILL IT LOOKS LESS.
SOME CARBON EMITTING ALL
SOURCES AS THE AS ALTERNATIVES
AND SO. I AM JUST OF A RAISING
GUN MY CONCERNS AND- AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL BE- NOT BE
VOTING FOR THE BILL TODAY. OKAY
STE BARK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD AND OTHERS WHO HAVE
SPOKEN TO SOME OF THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT MR SALAS IS DOING IN
THIS BILL I AM A DIE HARD
ENVIRONMENTAL LAST AND HAVE ONE
OF THE STRONGEST ENVIRONMENTAL
RECORDS IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
YET WE HAVE TO BE REAL ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING AND I THINK
THAT IS WHAT MR MURATSUCHI JUST
TOUCHED ON WHICH IS WE ARE
HAVING TO CENTER FOREST BECAUSE
AS WE ALL KNOW ONE OF THE
LARGEST EMISSIONS SOURCES RIGHT
NOW IS OUR WILDFIRES. AND THE
TOXIC AIR THAT IS COMING TO ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES WHETHER YOU
LIVE IN ONE OF THESE HIGH FIRE
GUNS OR NOT IS POISONING OUR
CHILDREN AND SO WE'RE DOING THE
WORK TO PREVENT THAT AND THAT
IS LEADING TO BIOMASS THERE ARE
OTHER SOURCES OF BIOMASS THAT
ARE OCCURRING IN OUR STATE WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
AND AN ALTERNATIVE SUCH AS THIS
WHICH- ALTHOUGH YES CREATING
EMISSIONS CONTAINS A LARGE
PORTION OF IT ESPECIALLY AS
COMPARED TO OPEN BURNING OR THE
WILD FIRES IF WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING. SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY
POSITIVE ALTERNATIVE AND I
THINK THAT'S THE WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO AND I AGREE WITH DR
QUIRK THAT WE NEED TO DO THAT
WORK AND WE NEED TO BE
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT IT AND WE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH EVERY
SINGLE TOOL IN OUR TOOLBOX AND
THAT MEANS LOOKING AT WHAT IS
THE ALTERNATIVE IF WE DON'T DO
THAT AND THE ALTERNATIVE TO NOT
DOING THIS IS WORSE FOR OUR
CLIMATE AND SO THAT IS WHAT IS
ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO STAND UP AND SAY I'M NOT
GOING TO SUPPORT THE POSITION
OF THE SIERRA CLUB HERE I THINK
THIS IS A BETTER ALTERNATIVE.
AND SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND I WISH. WE WERE DOING
MORE TO MOVE THIS FORWARD THANK
YOU. MEMBERS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO. COMMENT I THINK THAT FIRST
OF ALL IF THE STE THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO ANY OF
THE COMMENTS WILL DIRECT THAT
TO YOU IN YOUR CLOTHES IF
THAT'S FINE PLEASE- AND
CERTAINLY IF YOU NEED TO RELY
OR LOOK FOR ANY OF YOUR
WITNESSES TO ADD TO. YOUR
THOUGHTS BEFORE YOU CONCLUDE
WILL WILL LOOK TO THAT OF I
THINK WHAT WE'RE ALSO TRUMP
RECOGNIZES THIS IS ONE
CHALLENGING COMMITTEE TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH OF SOME VERY-
PROBLEMATIC FIRST OF ALL WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW. MUCH TO
DO AND HOW. TO MANAGE THOSE
EFFORTS AND ALL THE ARRAY OF
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE
AND- RESOURCES THAT ARE BEING.
GENERATED FOR US TO. REDUCE OUR
CARBON OUTPUT. FIGHT THE
WILDFIRES IN ODYSSEY OR-
IMPACTING ON OUR STATE AND I
THINK WERE YOU SEE IN YOUR
BILL. OF MISTER SALAS IS AN
EFFORT TO TRY TO BALANCE THE-
THE EFFORTS AND I DON'T
DISASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH ANY OF
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE OF THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION. AS BEST TO TRY
TO THREAD A NEEDLE HERE- BUT
ALSO TO RECOGNIZE YOUR GREAT
EFFORTS AND TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THOSE ARE HIGHLIGHTED
WERE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
A BILL THAT I THINK WE'LL GET
US MOVING AND MAYBE EVEN.
CREATING THE KIND OF ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT- HERE TODAY BY THE
MEMBERS SO- WITH THAT IT'S OUR
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD THIS BILL- AS AMENDED
AND- IF YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE WILL TURN TO YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
LET ME THANK EACH OF- MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN ON THIS
BILL THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT A
POLICY DISCUSSION THAT WE NEED
TO BE HAVING AND WE CAN'T BE
BLIND HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EFFECTS OF. NOT
HAVING THIS ALTERNATIVE RIGHT-
MY COLLEAGUES TALKED ABOUT
THESE OPEN FIELD BURNING AS I
SEE THEM ON THE DAILY
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT AYE
THREE CM THROUGHOUT CLIFORNIA.
RIGHT WHEN YOU SEE THE KIDS
THAT ARE SUFFERING FROM ASTHMA
SUFFERING FOR PM TWO POINT FIVE
FROM ALL OF THESE OTHER ISSUES
BECAUSE THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE IS
TO BURN THIS- WASTE WHETHER
IT'S IN A PILE OR WHETHER IT'S
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRES WE NEED
TO HAVE THESE ALTERNATIVES TO
NOT ONLY CREATE. HEALTHY FOR US
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WILDFIRES
THAT'S WHY IT'S PART OF THE
WILDFIRE FORCED LITIGATION PLAN
THAT'S WHY THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS CALLING FOR
MORE INVESTMENTS INTO. BIOMASS
FACILITIES THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
THE WIDE ARRAY OF COALITIONS
COMING TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THIS
AND- APPRECIATE- MISTER CORK
AND OTHERS WHO SAID THAT THE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM BECAUSE IT'S THE
TRUE DISCUSSION. THAT NEEDS TO
BE HAPPENING TO PUSH THIS
FORWARD I KNOW- WE WERE
COMPELLED TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION FROM. I BELIEVE AN
RTC AT SIERRA CLUB. WHO WHO
TESTIFIED EARLIER- BUT IS AN
IMPORTANT. I TO SEE YOU SEE
PAYING A- TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND WHERE WE WANT TO GO WE WANT
TO HAVE. PRACTICAL REAL
RESULTS- THAT HAVE AN IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES NOW AND
THIS IS A GOOD ALTERNATIVE. I
DON'T ONLY HELPS US MITIGATE-
WILDFIRES IN THE FUTURE BUT
ACTUALLY PROTECTS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS AND I.
RESPECT EVERYONE'S- COMMENTS
AND APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
COMMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MICHAEL. THANK YOU SIR IS
THERE A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
THE- DOCTOR QUIRK- MOVED AND
IT'S CARILLO SECOND. SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
TO NATURAL RESOURCES THE
SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL. I
AM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY TWO TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO NATURAL RESOURCES. HOLDEN
FIVE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BETTER CAN. PARA
QUE HAN I BURKE. BURKE HI
CORREA. CARILLO AYE CHAN CHEN
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO
GARCIA I MAYES MAYES I AM
MURATSUCHI. OUR CITY NOT VOTING.
QUIRK WORK I. REYES REYES ICE
SANTIAGO. TANG. TWELVE HIS
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON- MR SALAS BEFORE WE
MOVE MOVE TO YOUR YOUR SECOND
BILL LET ME JUST- MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT ON THE
ITEM THAT WE TOOK A VOTE ON
EARLIER IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT THE BILLS THAT WERE ON
CONSENT I THINK OR REFERENCE
AND EARLIER BUT JUST IN CONCERT
WITH A IN LINE WITH THE VOTE
ITSELF. THAT THAT REPRESENTED-
ARE MOVING AT ALL THROUGH CAN
SAID AB THREE FIFTY FOUR COOPER
WHICH TO PASS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND AB TWO FORTY TWO
HOLDEN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND THAT HAS
MOVED OUT OF OUR COMMITTEE-
MISTER CELL PHONE NUMBER TO YOU
ON YOUR I DON'T FIVE SIX NINETY
NINE ENERGY COMMISSION FLEXIBLE
THE MAN OF FINANCES REBATE
PROGRAM. THE MOTION IS OUR
SECOND. THERE'S MOTION A
SECOND- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION OF THE SECOND LET ME
JUST SAY THAT I'M PLEASE
PRESENT AB SIX NINETY NINE
WHICH WILL STOP MOTION YOU
REBATE PROGRAM TO HELP
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
PURCHASED SMART HOME APPLIANCES
LIKE THERMOSTATS PLUGS AND
POWER STRIPS. AND I DO HAVE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND
RESPECT- AND DEFERMENT TO THE
COMMITTEES TIME. THANK YOU ARE
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT TESTIFYING BY
PHONE. OR MODERATOR IF YOU CAN-
ALERT LILLIAN MARVIS- THAT SHE
IS WE'RE READY FOR HER
TESTIMONY. ONE MILLION YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHAREHOLDER THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MILLION
AMERICANS I'M WITH THE CENTER
FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY CENTER
FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY IS A
CALIFORNIA BASED NONPROFIT WITH
THE MISSION OF DECARBONIZE WE
YOU THERE BY ADMINISTERING
GOVERNMENT FUNDED MARKET
TRANSFORMATION PROGRAM. EQUITY
IN BOTH THE CLEAN ENERGY AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION THANK.
WHERE PROP ONE OF A SIX NINE
AND THANK FOR CALLING AND OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE APPRECIATE
THE TIME ABOUT SHAREHOLDER LIKE
MAYBE. PUT IN THE NUMBER BY THE
CELL. DURING THE OTHER TWENTY
TWENTY BLACKOUT CALIFORNIA
SAADIAN THING TO RESPONSE AND
THEN FOR GROWTH. IF I TO
IMPROVE RELIABLE. EIGHTY SIX
NINE HEALTH HEALTH FOR PREPARE
FOR FUTURE GRAMMAR. BY A QUICK
BLOW INCOME HOW WITH TOOLS I
RESPOND WITH THE GREATEST. I
THOUGHT ON WIFI ENABLED GREAT
NOT FIND AND EIGHTY SIX NINE
NINE PRADHAN FELT OF THE INNER
SAVINGS. PROGRAM THANK HER TO
MAKE RESPONSE PROGRAM.
FURTHERMORE A SIX NINE LET THE
WORK PERFORMED AT THE END OF
CALIFORNIA ENERGY CAN. I IN THE
FORTY NINE TWENTY NINE. I DON'T
HIM I'M PRETTY BONTA A
TWENTIETH SAN LOAD MANAGE ROLE
MAY AT THE END COMMISSION.
EIGHTY SIX NINE NINE FIVE THE
POLICIES IN THE REBATE PROGRAM
FOR. ON THE GROUND. IN THE
NATION. WELLFLEET EIGHTY NINE
AND HOW LOW HOW. TO UTILIZE
AFFORDABLE FACT AND ARE
EFFICIENT SOLUTIONS PROVIDE AND
FINING BENEFITS. I CONSERVING
ENERGY IN COSTS. THANK YOU
TERRY HOLDEN MEMBER HERE TIME
AND THAT ANY QUESTION YOU HAVE
AND I RESPECT ASK THAT. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR TEST WE
TURN. GREG WILCHER. WHAT COLOR-
WITH THE CAL EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TELLS
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDEN VICE
CHAIR PATTERSON AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GREG
WITH CLEAR AND I'M THE CHAIR
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING NEED DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL. THE COUNCIL
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE OF THE STATEWIDE TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF NON UTILITY
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND RESPONSE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. OUR
SEVENTY PLUS MEMBERS INCLUDE
COMPANIES AND ORGANIZATIONS WHO
EMPLOY A LARGE PORTION OF
CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT WORKFORCE. WE ARE
PROUD TO BE CO SPONSORS OF
EIGHTY SIX NINETY NINE AND
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
HIS STAFF FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
THOUGHT YOU AND THE COMMITTEE.
HAVE PUT INTO AMENDMENTS FOR
THIS BILL. EIGHTY SIX NINETY
NINE SIX TO EXPAND AND
MODERNIZE THE CQC'S CURRENT
ENERGY SAVINGS ASSISTANCE OR
KEY STEP PROGRAM BY ENABLING
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS. TO BE A
QUICKLY DEMAND RESPONSIVE
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS SMART
THERMOSTATS. IF IN TURN WILL
ALLOW THOSE CUSTOMERS. OTHER
CONSUMERS TO PARTICIPATE AND
RECEIVE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES IN
THE STATE'S NEWLY EXPANDING
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS AIMED
AT ENSURING ELECTRIC GRID
STABILITY DURING ANTICIPATED
POWER SHORTFALLS BROUGHT ABOUT
BY. CLIMATE CHANGE AND
PROLONGED HEAT STORMS. ITS
MODERNIZATION MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THESE ADVANCED SMART
TECHNOLOGIES ARE ACCESSIBLE AND
EQUITABLE IN THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION AND THAT
EVERYONE CAN FINANCIALLY
BENEFIT FROM THE FLAT FLEXIBLE
CAPACITY AND GREATER
RELIABILITY THEY BRING TO THE
SYSTEM. WHAT THE SAME TIME
LOWERING CARBON EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE SUFFERING
THE MOST. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON. EIGHTY SIX NINETY
NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IF WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO'S HERE IN THE BACK
OF THE CHAMBER WHICH I SEE NO
ONE IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER
NOR IN THE GALLERY- THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY WILL MOVE ON
TO. WITNESSES AND OUR WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. THERE IS
ANYONE. MY UNDERSTANDING IS IF
THERE IS ANYONE THEY JUST NEED
TO SPEAK AND THEY WILL. LIGHT
UP THE BOARD. OKAY WILL NOW
MOVE TO OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES AT ONE
OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON AB SIX NINETY NINE.
HEARING NONE OF THE PHONE LINES
ARE NOW OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON AB SIX NINETY NINE.
MODERATOR YOU WILL OPEN UP THE
LINES AND WE WILL. HERE ARE
COMMENTS OF SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
AND JUST STATING THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT AB SIX NINE NINE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY SIX NINE
NINE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE IN THE QUEUE LOCAL
TO LINE ONE ALL THREE PEOPLE I
HAD. LINE ONE OH THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. MAXIMO TO LINE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STILL THE- FERRARI ON BEHALF OF
MY PHONE CONNECTED IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NATURAL
MOTOR LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VINCENT WHAT
MADRE WITH THE CLIENT CENTERED
IN STRONG SUPPORT. MAXIMAL TO
LINE SEVEN NEED TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A BIRD WITH
LOCAL SUPPORTING A NEST
THERMOSTAT PARTNERSHIPS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX NINE NINE.
THANK YOU. NAKAMOTO LINE ONE OH
EIGHT PEOPLE HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE KERRY
BENTLEY OF THE BECAUSE THE
ENERGY. WHERE MANY FACTORS HOME
THAT HELP CUSTOMERS MANAGE
ENERGY WHILE HOLDING
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY GO I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY SIX NINETY NINE THANK
YOU. AND ACCESS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL
THEN CONSIDER PUBLIC COMMENT
CLOSE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER SALAS ON HIS
BILL. COMMENTS IS THERE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THE MOON
BY MAJORITY LEADER AND SECOND
BY- QUE HAN WE WILL NOW- US THE
PERSONAL. THREE LIKELY ASK
PRIVATE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH ADDITIONAL SECRETARY CALL
THE WHOLE WORLD THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCE. I DON'T NUMBER FIVE
A. B. SIX NINE NINE TWO PASSES
A MEDITATION RESOURCES HOLDEN
HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON UPLOADING PARA QUE
HAN. R. K. HAD AYE BURKE. BURKE
I CARILLO. CARRILLO AYE CHAN.
CHANNEL THIRTEEN CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI MESSAGES I
WORK. CORK REYES. REYES I SENT
TO. TING. THAT'S ELEVEN ICE-
THE BILL ITSELF AND WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. I WILL NOW MOVE BACK
TO ITEM TWO A. B. TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN TO THIS BAR MIDDLE
JUSTICE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
HUBS PROGRAM. SURGERY ON THE
FLOOR. GIVE US A FAIR LET ME
FIRST START BY THANKING YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING
WITH ME AND OUR COALITION ON
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL- I ACTUALLY WANT TO STATE
ON ACCEPTING ALL OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE REPORT. WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
ADDRESSING CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION TO SUMMARIZE
SOME OF THE KEY AMENDMENTS I'LL
BE ACCEPTING REDUCING OUR
REGIONAL PROPOSED ALLOCATION OF
THE CLIMATE CREDIT. FROM 85%
25% THE ORIGINAL BILL WOULD
APPLY TO RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
WHICH CREATED CONCERNS FOR
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING AMENDMENTS TO
COMPLETELY REMOVE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO RESIDENTIAL HOUSING
UPGRADES AND ONLY HAVE A BILL
FOCUSED ON CRITICAL COMMUNITY
INSTITUTIONS. OTHER MOMENTS
DIRECT THE CQC TO DEFINE KILLED
ABILITY REQUIREMENTS AND
ESTABLISH THAT THE PROGRAM WILL
SUNSET IN TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
I ALSO WANNA MENTION THAT I'VE
AGREED TO MAKE AN ADDITIONAL
MINUTE NOT REFLECTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TO LIMIT THE
BILL'S FUNDING SOURCE TO TEST
THE RESIDENTIAL CLIMATE CREDIT.
TO AVOID ANY IMPACTS TO THE
INDUSTRIAL ASSISTANCE CREDIT
AND THE SMALL BUSINESS CREDIT.
I BELIEVE THESE MOMENTS ADDRESS
MOST OF THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED I KNOW THE OPPOSITION
STILL REVIEWING AMENDED
LANGUAGE. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION. AB
TWENTY SEVEN A CUTE NEEDED AT
THIS MOMENT TO ADDRESS THE
MULTIPLE CRISES THAT OUR
COMMUNITY FACES. THIS IS A
COMMITTEE THAT KNOWS FULL WELL.
THAT THE CLIMATE CRISIS- IS
ESTABLISHING AN INCREDIBLE
THREATS FROM CLIMATE DISASTERS.
FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE POWER SHUT
OFFS AND HEAT WAVES. WE DON'T
KNOW DURING CLIMATE CRISIS
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGED. WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE SAFE SPACES AND
BUILDINGS. ARE VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS TO BE PROTECTED FROM
EXTREME CONDITIONS. RESILIENCE
CLUBS AREN'T INNOVATIVE
COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES. THIS
BILL WOULD BOLSTER COMMUNITY
INSTITUTIONS THAT ALREADY
EXIST. PUBLIC BUILDINGS LIKE
SCHOOLS LIBRARIES AND
HOSPITALS. COMMUNITY BUILDINGS
LIKE HEALTH CLINICS COMMUNITY
CENTERS HOMELESS SHELTERS
SENIOR U. CENTERS FOOD BANKS
PLACES OF WORK. THROUGH
HOLISTICALLY ENERGY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH OPERATES IT OFFER
COMMUNITY SAFE SPACES TO GATHER
TO ALLOW RESIDENTS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO SERVICES LIKE CLEAN
BACKUP POWER. REFRIGERATION FOR
MEDICINE AND FOOD AND CLEAN AIR
AND OTHERWISE BE PROTECTED FROM
CLIMATE CRISIS. THE CURRENT
PATCHWORK PROGRAM'S RESPONSES
AVAILABLE HAS NOT BEEN
SUFFICIENT FOR COMMUNITIES
WHILE THERE ARE SOME
INDEPENDENT PROGRAMS FOR. SOME
ITEMS COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE MAJOR OBSTACLES IN
ACCESSING THE COMPREHENSIVE
SUITE OF POSSIBILITIES THAT ARE
POSSIBLE THROUGH THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE LAID OUT
IN THIS BILL. BY REDIRECTING A
SMALL PORTION OF THE CLAIM OF
CREDIT THIS BILL MAKES POSSIBLE
THE POTENTIAL OF COMMUNITIES
GOT BENEFITS ACROSS OUR STATE.
IT POOLS THE FEW DOLLARS FROM
ALL OTHER VALUE CUSTOMERS
BESIDE LOW OUR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS TO MAKE DIRECT
REINVESTMENTS IN COMMUNITIES
THE WEATHER WAS WOULD NOT HAVE
THE CAPITAL TO ACCESS COMMUNITY
SCALE PROJECTS. WITH ME TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF BILL
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ARE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
CLINIC CHIANG. AND FROM EIGHT
TEN ON THE REBEL AND WITH THAT
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO OUR MAIN
WITNESSES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WILL LOOK
TO THE MODERATOR TO- REACH OUT
TO GLENN CHIANG SHE'S NOW UP
FOR. HER TESTIMONY. AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CLOSURE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GOING CHIANG AND I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
AS A CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND ALLIANCE OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE REPRESENTING WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
LIVING AT THE FRONT LINES OF
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AB SEVENTY SEVEN AT THE TOP
PRIORITY FOR US THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT
HARDSHIPS BROUGHT ON BY WILD
FIRES POWER OUTAGES IN A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND OTHER DISASTERS
AND THEY KNOW THAT THE TAKING
TWO MORE. TO HELP BUILD ONGOING
RESILIENCE. LAST YEAR RESIDENTS
THE EXPERIENCE. PULLING POWERS
OFF. AND YOU CAME IN TIME
WILDFIRES ARE SPREADING ACROSS
STATE. NEIGHBORHOODS IN
NORTHERN HEALTH WHERE IT'S- THE
HOTTEST OF THE- WHICH WAS
FOLLOWED BY WEEKS OF SMOKE
FILLED SKIES. WHILE SMOKE YEAH
I NEEDED IN VALLEY PROLONG
THEIR X. THESE EVENTS ARE TO
THE POOR AIR. THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES ALREADY FACE ON
BASIS. WITH TO IN THE- HIGHWAYS
PORTS AND WAREHOUSES. DESPITE
RESOURCE CONSTRAINTS. STRUCTURE
BUILT ON MUTUAL AID NETWORKS
GIVE OUT MOCK NONPROFIT TO OPEN
UP THEIR OFFICES IS. STATIONS.
AND REFRIGERATION. AND TO
ORGANIZER TO COMBAT IN OUT TO
RESIDENTS. ARE WE NEED HAVE TWO
THAT THEY TRY STATEMENT TO OR-
SO CALLING ON THE TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO SCALE
UP THE COMMUNITY DRIVEN AND
PLATE. TO APPROACHES. AB EIGHTY
SEVEN AND CHEN TO DO. BY
BOLSTERING THE LIKE AND IN
PUBLIC HEALTH UP WE AMPLIFY
STRENGTH OUR INCREASE OUR CAN
CAN RELY ON IT ON THE WHEN THEY
NEED BACKUP POWER. FOR JURY ON
CLEAN AIR. HELP HAS OXYGEN TO
CHANGE COURSE FROM HIS CYCLE OF
DISINVESTMENT IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND ON BUILDING TOWARD
RESILIENT CREATURE FOR EVERYONE
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS BIBLE ON
A BEACH. EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. HI AMY ARE BROUGH I
BELIEVE IS UP NEXT AS TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
HOLDEN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ON THE YOUR CALL WE SIX
TRACTOR WITH ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK AT&T
KERRIGAN BY MALL JUSTICE ASIAN
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES. WE ARE CO SPONSOR
ALONGSIDE THAT HOT AND OUR DC
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS. FOR DISTILLATE
BUILDING OFFICE VISION AND
LEADERSHIP OF A PLANNED
COMMUNITY. APRIL HAVE BEEN
COLLABORATING WITH THE RIDE YOU
CENTER IN RICHMOND IF THE COMIC
YOU LEAD WITH BILLION POUNDS
THAT INCLUDED CLEAN ENERGY
MICROGRID APPLICATION. AND
INCLUDE INSULATION. THREE THE
PROVIDED THE FIRST. COMMUNITY
HEALTH AS WELL CRISIS RESPONSE.
IT IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF OUR
VISION FOR A AND EIGHTY SEVEN
HOWEVER WE GET SIGNIFICANT
BERRIER IN FRONT THESE ARE.
WHAT DUE TO AND WE GAP THAT
HAVE MADE HARD FOR TO HELP. AND
SECURE STATE FUNDING. SECOND
THIS PROGRAM IS OPPORTUNITY
THIS WITH THE PUBLIC ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. BUT PROPER HUNDRED
NATURE THIS PRO. BREAKDOWN
ACROSS INDEED TECH. TODAY MY
BENEFITS. THE TECHNICAL WORK
FIFTY COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT MARC
STAKEHOLDER PARTNER AND
TARGETED ELIGIBILITY THIS BILL
AND PROTECT THE AREA
INVIGILATORS NEED IT MOST AND
FINALLY THIS BILL AIMS TO AVOID
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. WE
WANT TO THANK OUR WILLINGNESS
TO AMEND THE BILL TO ENSURE
THAT INDUSTRY GROUPS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE NOT ADVERSELY
IMPACTED AMENDMENT ALSO MADE IN
PPC AUTHORITY OVER THE CLIMATE
CREDIT WITH SPECIFIC
DIRECTIONS. TO SELECT AN
APPROPRIATE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR TO WORK PROJECT
AS WELL AS DETERMINE ELIGIBLE
BUILDINGS. AND UPGRADES THAT
QUALIFY. AB TWENTY SEVEN
COLLECTED FOR COME RESOURCE.
THAT INSURANCE WE HAVE. THE DOT
STRIKE. BELIEVES REASONS I
WOULD ASK YOUR- THING YOU.
THANK YOU. WELL NOW MY TO A
PRIMARY WITNESS WHICH WE HAVE
ONE AND OPPOSITION AND WILL BE
TESTIFYING BY PHONE BY
MODERATOR IS THERE ISRAEL SALAS
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC. IS
AVAILABLE FOR WERE AVAILABLE TO
HEAR HIS TESTIMONY. STE. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ISRAEL
SALAS AND I AM WITH SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION TO THE BILL AND
CRANK AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE
INTENDED TO REDUCE THE- IMPACT.
BUT WE HAVE TO NOTE THAT THE
BILL STILL TAKES AWAY A FORMER
BILL RELIEF AT A TIME WHEN. WE
ARE ALL LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
PROVIDE THE RELIEF TO MANY
CUSTOMERS THAT CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE CLIMATE
CREDIT IT'S AN AFFORDABILITY
TOOL FOR RATE PAYERS. AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THE TRANSITION
TO A LOW CARBON ECONOMY OUR
CUSTOMERS HAVE BEEN AND
CONTINUE TO MAKE THROUGH A
MYRIAD OF CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS AND PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY FOR SDG AND E.
CUSTOMERS- THE SEVENTY DOLLAR
CLIMATE CREDIT CAN BE THE
EQUIVALENT OF A MONTH'S
ELECTRIC BILL AND IF YOU ARE
AWARE OF THAT BEACHING YOU
RATES YOU KNOW THAT THING
SOMETHING. THAT WAS NOTED
EARLIER THAT LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS ARE EXEMPT BUT JUST
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THOSE
CUSTOMERS THAT WOULD LOSE A
PORTION OF THE CREDIT. THINK OF
A FAMILY OF FOUR ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OVER THE FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. THE
ONLY A FOR CARE INCOME LIMIT
THEY WOULD LOSE A PORTION OF
THE CREDIT. WE KNOW
AFFORDABILITY IS TOP OF MIND
FOR REGULATORS AND LAWMAKERS
AND BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL ADD
TO THE ALREADY CHALLENGING
LANDSCAPE FOR RAPE. A WHITE
PAPER DEVELOPED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IN ADVANCE
OF AN ALL DAY REYES WORKSHOP IN
FEBRUARY. FORECASTED THAT
ELECTRIC RATES COULD GO UP AS
MUCH AS FORTY SEVEN PERCENT.
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS SB
JENNY BUNDLED CUSTOMERS- WE
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THE COMMITTEE SHOULD CONSIDER
AS WE EVALUATE DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS BACK. IN ISOLATION
MAY NOT CONCERNING BUT
CUMULATIVELY ADD TO RATE
PRESSURES ILLUSTRATE ROUGHLY
2225% ABOUT THE GENIE'S RATE IS
THE RESULT OF. MANDATE THAT WE
IMPLEMENT- IF WE THINK ABOUT
THE UTILITY SECTOR C<c.cyan>G</c>
PRECIPITATING AND LEADING ON
THE KLAMATH FALLS AFFORDABLE
ELECTRIC RATE. WILL BECOME
INCREASINGLY CRUCIAL GOING
FORWARD AND THEN LASTLY I WANT
TO APOLOGIZE FOR NOT DOING THIS
IN OUR LETTER BUT IF THE BILL
DOES CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
TO GIVE US THE ABILITY TO OPT
OUT OF ADMINISTERING ANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS. I'M EXTREMELY
ATTRACTED THE TPC WOULD DECIDE
BETWEEN US. FOR A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR- AND WE I PREFER
TO BE IN A- TO NOT HAPPY.
ADMINISTER THE PROPOSAL NEW
PROGRAM. WE DO A PRE COMMITTEE
WORK ON THE BILL THE AUTHOR
EXCEPT OF THE AMEND. AND WE
WERE. OUR CHURCH REVIEW ALL OF
THE- WHEN THEY ARE INCORRECT
THANK YOU FOR THE UP. TO SHARE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU AND I THINK
YOU'RE- PRETTY CLEAR IN TERMS
OF YOUR POSITION. AS IT RELATES
TO THE AMENDMENTS BUT I WAS. SO
YOU'RE CONTEMPLATING THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT MIGHT REMOVE
YOUR OPPOSITION BUT WITH THE
EXPECTATION OF CONTINUING TO
WORK. WITH THE AUTHOR. YES WILL
HAVE TO CAREFULLY REVIEW- WHAT
THIS MEANS IN TERMS OF AN
IMPACT THAT THE RATE
PERSPECTIVES YOU NEED A FULL
DEFINITELY BE IN TOUCH WITH YOU
IN THE OFFICE OFFICE. A PERSON
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- AND WE HAVE NO
ONE. IN THE CHAMBERS EITHER IN
THE GALLERY ON THE FLOOR WHO IS
PREPARED TO ADD ANY TESTIMONIES
WILL TURN TO WITNESSES IN THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM- IF
THERE'S ANYONE THERE THAT
WOULD. LIKE TO PRESENT THEIR
TESTIMONY WILL RECEIVE IT NOW.
SAY NONE LET'S GO TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AT ONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A. B.
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN. THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN AB TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. THIS MODERATOR DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES OR
ANYONE ON THE LINE THE REALIST
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. OR HAVE SHARE
CONCERNS ON AB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BUT WE WILL BE JUST TAKING.
NAME AND AFFILIATION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN FERAL
NOW AGAIN ONE BEEN. ZERO
FOXFIRE WHAT LINE. ONE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO SHOULD
EVERYTHING FROM THE LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH A SUPPORT
AGENT OF PETITIONS TO ENSURE
PROVISION FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
ABOUT EXISTING COMMITTEE
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN STILL
BENEFIT FROM THE IMPORTANT
GOING- COMMITTEE BASED MODEL
THANK YOU. THANK MATT WELL
BOTTOM LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PEOPLE
HAD. I AMBULANCE AT THE
COALITION FOR CALIFORNIA GREEN
DEAL CALLING AND THE STRONG
SUPPORT AND THAT WOULD BE
REALLY TIME CAN BACK THEN
BECAUSE AND COMMUNITY ON THE
LINE AND THE BILL WILL DOES
THAT I STRENGTH AFTER ALREADY
BEING UNDER BY THEM THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND AS A REMINDER AT
NAME AFFILIATION AND WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE NEXT
LEVEL TO LINE ONE NO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JIM DOLAN STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION WITH A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TIMELINE FORTY PLEASE
CALL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN BERKELEY IS
OVER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE YOUR
MEANING IN PUBLIC LIFE
CONDITIONS RESPECT THE HOME
SOURCE THE ACCOUNT AND TRADE.
MAXIMO TO ONE ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE CALL I HAD. ONE ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOT YET WE CAN. HI
HELLO THIS IS PUBLIC OUR LOW
AND I AM- IF SUPPORTERS AB T.
NAY SEVEN ON THE OF FOR OUR-
LISTEN TO THE- OKAY YOU. MAX OF
TIELINE SIX ONE PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
CALTRAIN ON BEHALF OF BOTH
SOLAR INTO. NOT CAROLINA ONE
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. G. MINOR ON
THE OF A THE BUT THAT'S A
AMENDED MCCORD WILL CAME DOCTOR
AND DOCTOR ENCOURAGED FIFTY
EIGHT AND PROGRAM. THANK.
MAXIMAL TELL FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO OUT. ASSEMBLY ABOUT BEHALF
OF IN THE ENERGY WITH THE C.
AND OPPOSITE THANK YOU. MAX TO
LINE THEIR NINE PLEASE CALL I
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON YEAH BOARD
FROM TELE CAL EDISON AND WE'RE
NOT. NOW OF THE LINE EIGHT
PLEASE GO OUT. NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN NUMBER
THANK IT ACROSS THE WITH
ANOTHER RESOURCE DEFENSE
COUNCIL ENERGY PEOPLE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR KENNEDY SEVEN WITH A
PEN AND SAY HANDY LIKE TO THE
OF SOMETHING CHIU FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
NOT THE MOST ONLINE. FIVE WE'VE
GOT. HELLO AND MERRY WERE- WITH
THE RE OUR POWER UTILITY
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN THIS COULD ENERGY
TREND BY JUSTICE CAN. IMPACTED
BY THE FOR TV AND SHUT UP THANK
YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINE ONE- OO
FIVE PLEASE AHEAD. IN A BROAD
ON BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB CAL AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO
LINE ONE TWELVE PLEASE CALL I
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CAPTAIN
FOSTER FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION AND WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT SOME OF THE LINE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BARBARA STEPHENS WITH LOCAL
CLEAN ENERGY ALLIANCE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN AS A CRITICAL TOOL
FOR FRONTLINE COMMUNITY BEEN
VALIANT. THANK YOU. MAXIMO
CAROLINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE
WELL I HAD. THIS IS THE LEAST
VAN **** WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. NOT SOMEONE TO LINE ONE
CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LORD
GAVE THEM GOT THE CALIFORNIA
MADE IT BACK TO THE TECHNOLOGY
SO SHE SHOULD BE OLD ENOUGH
HOLD ON LET POSITION. MAX OF
CAROLINE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS GRAYSON FLOOD FROM
PEOPLE POWER QUAL AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT TODAY SEVEN
THANK YOU. NEXT SOME OF TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT MOTHER PART WITH THE
WESTERN CAPE THE THIRTY WE CAN
PUBLIC ELECTED CONDITION
LOOKING TO B. AND B. MEN AND
OUTLINED BY OUR IF YOU. MATT
TIMELINE ON OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME ME
YES WE CAN OKAY GREAT ADDED
AFTERNOON GOVERNOR ALLOWED BUT
THE NORTH PLEASE ORGANIZED
CRIED- THE PART OF THE FRONT
LINE. AND WE ARE IN AND
GRATITUDE FOR THE ORGAN AND
GIVE THEM A TO HAVE CHAMPIONED
WITHOUT. MATT FROM OF THE LINES
TO FOUR PLEASE WHAT. THANK YOU
NAY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOLLOW CHAU HOSTED THE GAS NOT
HAD. WE HAVE OPPOSED TO LOOKING
FOR TO READING THE AND THEN.
THANK YOU. MAX OF THE LINE AB
PLEASE FOR. DANIEL GOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE YOUTH WILL THAT
TURN WITHIN A UNLESS MEN
POSITION. MAXIM OF TIELINE ONE
OF VERY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME AFTER ONLY IT FOR. THEM
LEARN JUSTICE FOR CATHOLIC
CHARITIES DIED THE STOCK CAN I
STRONGLY A. B. TEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
SIX PLEASE FOR. THANK YOU MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHAYLA ON
NINE ONE HIM AND CLIMATE I'M
CALLING INTO STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY. THANK YOU.
MAXIM OF THE LINE FOR EIGHT
PLEASE AHEAD. L. Y. ROVER
COORDINATOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE RECOVERY ENTER-
STRONGLY INTO OF. RESOURCES TO
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF COMMUNITY BASED
AND COMMUNITY DRIVEN RESILIENT
TOGS CONCERNED ABOUT- CUT AND
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO REQUIRE
A CREDIT ANALYST. MAXIMAL TO
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL
I HAD. WINDS SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU A
PHONE MODERATOR YOU CAN CLOSE
THE LINE WE WILL CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BRING IT BACK. TO
THE MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS DR QUIRK.
SO I AGREED THAT WE SHOULD BE-
PROBABLY BE INSULATING THE
BUILDINGS THAT WE HAVE OUR
SHELTERS IN IT CETERA. BUT I
FIND THIS A VERY. DIFFICULT
PROCESS FIRST OF ALL THE POINT
OF THIS MONEY THE 15% PLUS 5%
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY FROM RATE
PAYERS AND I'VE A FEELING THAT
THAT'S THE CONCERN OF THE
NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED DECISIVE 5%
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY FROM RATE
PAYERS AND THEREFORE INCREASING
THEIR COSTS. I CAN DEAL WITH
THAT IF I'M REALLY SURE. THAT
THIS MONEY IS BEING SPENT SO
WHICH WILL REALLY PROMOTE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
IS BEING USED FOR ALL SORTS OF
THINGS THAT DON'T. REALLY
AREN'T THE BEST WAY AND I KNOW
THAT'S A SEPARATE FUND BUT THEY
REALLY ARE THE BEST WAY TO
REDUCE OUR GREENHOUSE GASES THE
TRAIN BEING THE MOST OBVIOUS
ONE. THEY. YOU KNOW IF. FIXING
A HOMELESS SHELTER IS THE BEST
USE OF MONEY TO REALLY YOU KNOW
DO ENERGY CONSERVATION SAVE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY USED IN
BUILDINGS I'M ALL FOR IT THAT'S
THE CRITERIA I WANT WHAT YOU'VE
GOT HERE IS. THESE GRANTS YOU
HAVE TO HAVE SOME SORT OF JYJ
COMMUNITY OUTREACH WHICH IS
GONNA BE VERY EXPENSIVE. AND
CLEARLY IT'S IN IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHO WILL EVEN DO IT. I'M PRETTY
SURE THE PEOPLE WHO RUN THE
HOMELESS SHELTERS IF THEY
WANTED TO COULD MAKE IN A COULD
MAKE AN APPEAL RIGHT NOW TO THE
LOCAL UTILITY THAT THEY WANT TO
DO ENERGY CONSERVATION. IF THEY
WERE TO DO THAT. LIKE
HOMEOWNERS THEY COULD DO IT.
NOTHING IS STOPPING THESE
INSTITUTION FROM ASKING FOR
MONEY NOW WHY DO WE NEED THIS
PROCESS. WHY DO WE NEED THIS AT
ALL AGAIN. THESE ORGANIZATIONS
CAN JUST ASK PG&E SENDS PEOPLE
OUT ALL THE TIME TO TALK TO
SMALL BUSINESSES TRYING TO GET
THEM TO FIX THINGS UP WHY AND
I'M SURE YOU HAVE A GOOD REASON
BUT I STILL DON'T KNOW THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE TO DO IT
THIS WAY AND I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE OVERHEAD. THE
SECURITY LIKE TO RESPOND
ABSOLUTELY AND- AND I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- THE PERSPECTIVE OF
OUR COLLEAGUE LET ME FIRST SAY
A FEW THINGS- THIS BILL HAS
BEEN AMENDED ORIGINALLY WE HAD
PROPOSED TO USE 85% OF THE
CLIMATE CREDIT- BUT- AT THE
GOOD SUGGESTION OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR- WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT 5% OF CLIMATE CREDIT.
JUST TO. TELL EVERYONE WHAT
THAT MOUTH TURNS OUT TO BE IT'S
ABOUT TWO DOLLARS AND SEVENTY
CENTS. FOR EVERY RATE PAYER
WHO'S NOT LOW INCOME SO COMES
OUT TO ABOUT TWENTY TWO AND A
HALF CENTS PER PER MONTH SO I
JUST WANT TO. PUT THAT IN IN
SCALE- CERTAINLY THERE IS
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
CREATES- ANY REQUIREMENT- ON
THE STATE OR THE COST AROUND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH WHAT WE'RE
SAYING HERE IS. DURING THIS
TIME PERIOD. OF CLIMATE CRISIS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE COMMUNITY CENTERS AND
COMMUNITY HOGS. THAT ARE
DEFENSIBLE AGAINST CLIMATE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT YOU HAD
WILDFIRES AND HAD SMOKING AND
HEAT. WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
SPACES PARTICULARLY IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
IN LOW INCOME DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS TO USE THAT
PART OF MONEY. TO BE ABLE TO
FIRST MAKE THOSE BUILDINGS ARE
MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT WHICH
GETS TO WHAT YOU ALLUDED TO
AROUND GREENHOUSE GASES BUT
ALSO TO CREATE RESILIENT
COMMUNITY HUBS TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY.
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT BECAUSE THE
ALTERNATIVE THAT IS THE STATUS
QUO WHICH IS AGAIN SO MANY OR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
ARE ARE EXPOSED TO THE ELEMENTS
NOW- YOU MISTER PARKING ON YOUR
TEXT IN A LITTLE BIT BEFORE-
AND WE WERE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU WOULD
REFER TO ABOUT THE FACT THAT-
WE HAD ENVISIONED. THAT IN THE
APPLICATION TO THE SEE PICS OF
SO THE PROCESS OF THIS IS THE
C. P. C. WOULD PICK UP OUR
PARTY MINISTER. WILL STATUS THE
GUIDELINES NOW WITH THOSE
GUIDELINES COULD ABSOLUTELY
REFLECT WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO ABOUT. ADDRESSING GREENHOUSE
GASES BUT WE ALSO DO SO IN THE
BILL THAT WE WANT. COMMUNITY-
SO WORK FOR THESE PROJECTS.
WHETHER IT'S PART. SCHOOL THAT.
HOW THAT IS THE COMMUNITY HUB
AND SAY SANDRA- OR LA. FREMONT
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS SOME COMMUNITY INPUT ON THAT
BUT THAT'S SIMPLY. WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS AS AS THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. THE ADMINISTRATOR
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCEPT
INFORMATION. THAT REFLECT
COMMUNITY. BY AND THAT THIS
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY HUB. IS
THE BEST PLACE IN THIS
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY TO- TO
DEVOTE SOME RESOURCES SO
THAT'S- THAT'S WHAT THAT
LANGUAGE IS ABOUT. I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU- TO
ADDRESS THAT LANGUAGE TO MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR THAT THE
ADMINISTRATOR. WILL HAVE
OBJECTIVE CRITERIA TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING THE
GREENHOUSE GAS CONCERNS. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BUT ALSO. MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A RESILIENT
COMMUNITY HOUSE. THANK YOU.
THRIFT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR AUTHORING
THIS BILL I APPRECIATE HIM
DOING THAT I ALSO APPRECIATE
HIS COMMITMENT TO ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES NOT BE LEFT BEHIND
IN THE GREENREVOLUTION-
FOCUSING CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
INVESTMENTS IN POLLUTION BURDEN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES SHOULD
ALWAYS BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR CLIMATE. PROGRAM I THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK PROVIDES
GREAT RESOURCES FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST IN
NEED. I'M GLAD ALSO HE IS
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
TAKE CARE OF THE TO JUST THEIR
CONCERNS AND I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE. THAT
WERE- PUT IN THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. SUMMATION.
JUST WANTED TO SPEAK UP-
BRIEFLY SET AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW- I STILL HAVE- SCARS IF
NOT OPEN WOUNDS ALL OVER THE
WORK THAT WE DID IN REGARDS TO
CAP AND TRADE JUST A FEW A FEW
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS REPUBLICAN
LEADER- ONE OF THEM THE MOST
THE SALIENT POINTS THAT WE MADE
UP OF OUR ON OUR PRINCIPLES WAS
TO TRY TO GET ALL OF THE
DOLLARS BACK TO RATE PAYERS
WITHIN THE FORM OF SOME SORT OF
A- A CREDIT THAT WAS. EIGHT ONE
OF OUR ONE OF OUR OUR TEN
PRINCIPLES. IT HASN'T BEEN TEN
YEARS HASN'T BEEN FIFTEEN YEARS.
I HASN'T BEEN. FIVE YEARS IT'S
BEEN LESS THAN FIVE YEARS WERE
ALREADY CHANGING THE PROGRAM IT
MAKES IT DIFFICULT- AS A MEMBER
OF THIS LEGISLATURE TO SAY HEY
CUT A DEAL MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT AND THEY WERE JUST
GONNA CHANGE CHANGE THE RULES
TO VIEW A FEW YEARS LATER I
REALIZE OF THE AUTHOR HAS GONE
FROM 85% 25% APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY DIFFICULT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE G. G. R.
F. DOLLARS. WE'RE SPENDING THAT
ON ALL SORTS OF THINGS. NOT
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IF YOU BELIEVE LIKE I
DO. YOU LIVE LIKE I DO. BUT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A VERY REAL.
EXISTENTIAL THREAT. THAT OUR
GOAL SHOULD BE TAKING THOSE
DOLLARS AND DOING WHATEVER WE
CAN TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND BEING THE MOST
EFFICIENT IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IT
SHOULDN'T BE A REVENUE STREAM
FOR OTHER PROJECTS ALBEIT NOT
SUPPORTING IT TODAY JUST OUT OF
PRINCIPLE. THANK YOU. BEIJING
I'M NOT SURE WHAT I CAN- BUT
ANYWAY WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR- LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT
AND THE LEADERSHIP THAT YOU
SHOWED AND A VERY IMPORTANT
TIME AND I THINK CLEARLY THIS
COMMITTEE RECOGNIZES THAT THE-
SOME OF THE ELEMENTS OF OUTSIDE
OF THIS COMMITTEE GIGI ARE A
FUNDING IS HANDLED IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT AS WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND EVALUATING THESE
TYPES OF BILLS AND SEE THE
EFFORT AND THE ENERGY FOCUSING
ON- AND ADMITTEDLY IT'S AN
AMBITIOUS- PLAN- BUT I THINK
IT'S VERY LAUDABLE THAT WERE
LOOKING TO TRY TO IDENTIFY.
RESILIENT C. N. COMMUNITIES-
FOR ALL THE STATED REASONS THAT
THE AUTHORS IDENTIFIED WITH THE
INCREASE OF WILDFIRES AND
CERTAINLY THE IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR FOOTHILL
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF-
THAT ARE USUALLY OVERLOOKED- SO
I DO SUPPORT THE BILL- BUT I DO
WANT TO MISTER TEEN WHO HAD. A
QUESTION OR COMMENT- TO BE ABLE
TO WEIGH IN ON IT DID JUST A
QUICK POINT OF A CLARIFICATION
I KNOW MY OFFICE HAD REACHED
OUT TO- ABOUT MY ARE
COLLEAGUE'S OFFICE REGARDING
THE- DEFINITION I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A DEFINITION AROUND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUITIES AND
USUALLY WE'VE ASKED THE PAST TO
HAVE- THE DEFINITION AROUND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AS PART OF
THE- I KNOW THAT YOUR OFFICE
HAD MENTIONED THAT YOU WERE
USING THE DEFINITION OF
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. WITH
THE IDEA THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO BE- REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION
BECAUSE I THINK THE CONCERN IN
THE PAST WAS THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WOULD WOULD LEAVE
OUT THE YOU KNOW THE POOR
COMMUNITIES THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN BERNARD DINO HAS
TALKED ABOUT IN THE BAY AREA SO
I JUST WANTED TO JUST ASK A
POINT OF CLARIFICATION AND SEE
IF THAT IN FACT WAS WAS CORRECT
IN YOUR. YOUR SORT OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT WAS MORE.
BASED ON THAT BOTTOM
COMMUNITIES- DEFINITION IT WAS
MORE OF A REACH. YOU KNOW READ
POWER OF AROUND STATE SERVICE
AREA APPS. THE AT THE AT TEN OF
THIS BILL. IS A KNOW ARE
COMMUNITIES THE STATE I JUST
HAVEN'T GOT THE RESOURCES- AND
I THINK ARE CALLING FROM SAN
BERNADINO KNOWS THIS VERY WELL
PARTICULARLY. COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN HARDEST HIT BY
CLIMATE CRISIS SO WE DO- BASED
ON ALL PR'S CURRENT DEFINITION
OF VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
THOSE COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCING
A HEIGHTENED RISK INCREASE
SENSITIVITY TO CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT HAVE LESS TO PASS A FEW
RESOURCES TO COPE WITH. THE
DEATH TO RECOVER FROM CLIMATE
IMPACTS THERE IS ALSO ANOTHER
ELEMENT TO THE BILL IT REFERS
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION OF THIS FUNDS SO
IT DOESN'T ALL GO. TO CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE STATE SO WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO SPREAD OUT-
THE FUNDING THAT WE HAVE- TO
ADDRESS. THOSE NEEDS GREAT
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW. ALL RIGHT
SO- ISSUE WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR- YOUR
EFFORTS IN THIS BILL-
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THE
STAFF AND- THE COMMITTEE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS YOU GO FORWARD- WE THINK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT STEP THAT
YOU'RE TAKING A MORE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY IS
THERE A MOTION THAT WE CAN
ENTERTAIN IT'S BEEN MOVED IS
OUR SECOND. IT'S BEEN SECOND
TO- THE MOTION IS DUE PASSES
AMENDED- MAKE NATURIST TO
NATURAL RESOURCES. I REMEMBER
TWO AB TEN EIGHTY SEVENTY
PASSES AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
EYEING PATTERSON. PATTERSON NO
BETTER QUE HAN WHERE CAN I
BURKE. CAREER I CHEN. CHEN NO
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA HI MAYES.
MAYES NOW MURATSUCHI. MESSAGE
KNOW VOTING WORK. QUICK LOADING
REYES. REYES I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I'D TEAM. SAY AGAIN.
TANG I. THAT'S NINE AYE AYES TO
NOES. OKAY THE BILL ITSELF
REGULATIONS AND WE WILL HOLD
THE- A ROLLOVER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE TERM OR
LESS ITEM FOR THE DAY IS THIS
ITEM SIX AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
CRISTINA GARCIA WATER
CORPORATIONS BILL PAYMENT PILOT
PROGRAM. IT'S BEEN SET- THERE'S
A THIRD THERE'S OF. WHICH IS
OKAY. THE EXTENT TO EXISTING
OVERSEE MY THE C. P. TO ALLOW-
CAN SEE TO PAY FOR THEIR BILL.
ONLINE USING A CREDIT CARD OR
DEBIT CARD I THINK WE'LL ASK
FROM I'VE. THANK YOU- THE AND
THE AMENDMENTS. AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- CAN OFFER I
ACCEPTED ALL THE AMOUNT OF
THANK YOU HELP WONDERFUL YOU WE
HAVE TO WITNESS AND SAID OF BY
EVAN JAKE IF EVAN IS WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY NOW. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARES COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I WILL- KEEP THIS SHORT
MY NAME IS SEVEN JACOBS ON THE
CALIFORNIA. WATER WE ARE IF YOU
SEE REGULATED WATER UTILITY I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF. AB FIFTY
EIGHT- REALLY APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA OPPOSITION SOMETHING WE
HAVE BEEN PARTNERED ON WITH HER
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN- WE
WOULD SIMPLY LIKE A CHANCE TO.
EXPAND AND EXTEND OUR- PILOT
PROGRAM MY COMPANY WE GOT OUR
START I APRIL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN YOU CAN IMAGINE. ALL
OF THE CHANGES HAVE OCCURRED-
IN THE USE OF CREDIT DEBIT AND
PREPAID CARDS- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND- VERY NEW
REALITY WE LIVE IN TERMS OF
TOTAL BENEFITS SOCIAL
DISTANCING. SAFETY THE ABILITY
TO USE ONLINE COURT FOR BILLING
AND PAYMENTS. SHARES OF AND-
HAVING YOUR REQUEST THANK.
THANK YOU. ARE OUR NEXT
WITNESSES JUST. SCARR CAL WATER
SERVICE'S. BACK IN YOUR CHAIR
ALL THE MATH OF THE CAN- NAME
IS JOE SCARR THAT SHE THE CALL
COMMITTEE THE CAL WATERS FIFTY
EIGHT- I'M HERE TODAY TO.
ASSEMBLY BILL TENTATIVE EIGHT
I'D LIKE TO ECHO WHAT HAVE BEEN
SAID ABOUT THINKING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA I TOLD
HER ON THE WAY LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE- AS
EVIDENCE THE PILOT PROGRAM THAT
SAID THE BILL WOULD EXTEND
ALLOW THEIR CUSTOMERS USE THE
PREFERRED METHOD OF PAYMENT I
WITHOUT HAVING TO THE CURRENT
DIVISIONAL. IF THEY CHOOSE TO
USE ELECTRONIC FORMS OF PAYMENT
LIKE A DEBIT CARD- CERTAINLY
BECOME A PANDEMIC IS SHOWING
ALL THE TIME VALUABLE IMPORTANT
IS TO BE ABLE TO OFFER THESE
TYPES OF CONTACTLESS PAYMENT
METHODS TO OUR CUSTOMERS I AND
WE ASK FOR THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FIFTY EIGHT AND. HELP OUR
CUSTOMERS THANK YOU APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. WELL NOW MOVES
TO PUBLIC COMMENTED WE HAVE WE
HAVE NO ONE. ON THE FLOOR IN.
THE GALLERY WHO'S HERE TO
TESTIFY. TO HAVE WITNESSES IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. C.
NINE WILL NOW GO TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY OR OTHER ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. BY REMOTE STATIONS.
HEARING NONE OF THE PHONE LINES
ARE NOW OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. TO AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
AND THAT IS JUST TAKING THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. MODERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR EIGHTIES TEN
FIFTY EIGHT PRESS THE ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON NOW AGAIN ONE BEEN.
ZERO FOR EIGHTY TEN FIFTY EIGHT
AM SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. NOW
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTEEN WELL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS OF MY
BETTER LUCK WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
WATER SERVICE AND SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE WILL THEN CLOSE
THE A PUBLIC CANNOT COMMENT ON
THE PHONE LINES AND WILL TURN
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THAT
MEMBERS HAVE. FOR THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE- WE WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION AND A SECOND WE DON'T
WE'RE GOOD TO GO THAT'S RIGHT
WE HAVE FOUR. I'M THINKING
ABOUT- GARCIA WILL TURN YOU ANY
CLOSING RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE OKAY THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I AM NUMBER SIX
AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT DO PASS OF
THE MONITOR PREPARATIONS HOLDEN
HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I POWER QUE HAN. PARA
QUE HAN I BURKE. BURKE I
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CHAN. CHEN
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I. EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I MAYES MAYES I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE CORK.
QUIRK I REYES. REYES I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I EIGHTEEN. TANG HAI
THAT'S FIFTEEN EISNER KNOWS. A
FIFTEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT-
CONGRADULATIONS WILL NOW MOVE
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE FILE SO
MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON ANY OF
THE MEASURES INCLUDING THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE'LL START
WITH CONSENT CALENDAR. AND THEN
MAKE OUR WAY DOWN THE FILE. FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR YES. A. B.
THREE FIFTY FOUR DO PASSED THE
NATURAL RESOURCES. AB TWO FOUR
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING
I'D VICE CHAIR I. BURKE BURKE I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO
GARCIA I CHANGE. TANG HAI
THAT'S FIFTEEN EYES ZERO K.
FIFTY NUYS THE BILL THE CONSENT
CALENDARS OUT. ADAM. ONE I ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHT FOUR THREE
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING
I'VE VICE CHAIR I BETTER QUE
HAN. PARA QUE HAN I CARILLO.
CORREO I. TEN KING HI THAT'S
FIFTEEN EYES ZERO KNOWS THOSE
OUT FIFTEEN OUT. ITEM NUMBER.
TWO I'M SORRY ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB. THREE TWO TWO. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES CHAIR VOTING
I. VICE CHAIR I. SANTIAGO. KING
ARE KING HI THAT'S THIRTEEN
EYES ZERO KNOWS BILL AS WELL
THERE TO YOU KNOW PROVIDE A
NUMBER FIVE A. B. SIX NINE NINE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES CHAIR VOTING I. VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING. SANTIAGO
THANK TING HI THAT'S TWELVE
EYES ZERO KNOWS BILLS OUT
GLOBAL. ITEM NUMBER SIX. AB TEN
FIFTY EIGHT DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THAT
BELLA'S THAT IS FIFTEEN ZERO.
FIFTEEN IS SERRANO'S. IT WAS A-
ADD UP TO THE RULES. YES WE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE- THE
VOTE FOR ADOPTION OF THE RULES
FOR ANY MEMBER THAT DID NOT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON
THE WAY. ON THE ROLE SO WILL
OPEN THOSE UP NOW MADAM
SECRETARY CALLED. AT CHAIR
VOTING I. NOW THIS IS FOR THAT
OPTION OF THE ROLLS CARE VOTING
IS VICE CHAIR AYE BURKE.
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I. TEN THAT'S
TWELVE IS SERRANO'S. OKAY
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR
TODAY I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU
BEING HERE AND CONTRIBUTING AS
YOU HAVE ALWAYS THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.